So I'm pleased to introduce Dr Eric
Chudler who has a bs Ms and phd in
psychology from Udab where he's the
executive director for the center of since
sensory motor neural
engineering at the udub.
He's a research associate professor in
the Department of bioengineering and
anesthesiology and pain medicine.
He is investigating the
neuroactive properties of
medicinal herbs and plants to
help treat neurological disease.
And Dr Leads Johnson,
I hope I pronounce both your
names correctly. I didn't.
Oh, great man. Um, who,
who is a research scientist in the
department of neurological surgery.
She has a bs in physics and a phd
in biomed biomedical engineering.
She is broadly interested in ECR based
brain based brain computer interfaces,
specifically in how the brain
changes in response to training.
They both share a passion for helping
improve science literacy and education as
well as developing the next
generation of scientists.
They here to talk about their book,
Brain Bites,
quick answers to quirky questions about
the brain. Please join me and give them,
give them a warmup.
[inaudible]
okay,
well thank you David and thank you to
a Google for inviting us here today.
Uh, all that stuff that David mentioned
introducing us means that we're really
interested in how the brain works.
Both Lisa and I are are neuroscientists
at the University of Washington. Uh,
we work at the center for sensorimotor
neuroengineering where we're developing a
bi-directional brain computer interface
to help people with neurological
problems, especially those with
stroke and spinal cord injury.
And today we're going to talk
about, uh, how your brain works.
So maybe we'll take it back to your high
school or you're a university level, uh,
neuroscience courses of
your biology courses.
We'll find out what you
know about the brain,
but just be a quick introduction
to the brain. And then,
uh,
Dr. Johnson and I have picked out two
of our favorite things to talk about the
brain. I'll talk about, does the
full moon make people go crazy?
And then we'll get some of
your opinions as well. Uh,
at least we'll talk about a
brain computer interfaces. Uh,
and then we'll just open up
for questions. Um, so, uh,
the plan is to introduce your brain
and when you think about the brain, uh,
the brand does about everything.
Uh, that's important to you. So, uh,
right now I'm moving, I'm
speaking, my heart is pumping,
my lungs are going in and out
there.
I lost my mind for a little
while. Sorry. Uh, uh,
but you bring it does just about
everything that's important to you. Uh,
it controls your emotions.
It controls all your movement.
And Crow controls were five senses.
Even though sense is that we don't even
think about our brain is helping us do.
So if you go ahead and put
your out in front of you,
and if you're wasn't your brain
telling you to put your arm out there,
if you couldn't see your arm, you still
get information about where your arm is.
Because after a while your arms
are gonna start hurting, right?
And so that part of your
body is your muscles.
So your muscles have sensory organs in
it that sends information to your spinal
cord and up to your brain.
Also in all of your joints,
your joints have sensory receptors and
them to tell where your arms are in space
and your legs are in space. Uh, hopefully
the words coming out of my mouth though,
sound pressure is changing and
it gets into your ear, your ear,
then your eardrum vibrates. If
those three bones, your ear vibrate,
they send messages to the auditory nerve
that are getting to your brain so that
you understand the words that
are coming out of my mouth. Uh,
so the brain is really, I think, the
most important part of your body.
And you really can't do without a brand,
uh,
like you can do without
other parts of your body.
And I think it's the most interesting
part of the body. So can you live,
for example, without a kidney?
Yeah. You can live without a kidney.
Can you live without a couple of feet
of intestine? Yeah. You got, you know,
20 or so feet of a test you could do
though. Can you live without your heart?
Yeah, sure you can. You can
live without your heart, right?
You can't live without a heart.
Right. And what about brain?
Can you live without your
brain? Can you maybe, maybe,
maybe not, maybe not, not,
not, not yet. Not yet.
Uh, and, uh, an interesting, uh,
question comes up that is if you could
take a brain and you can take this brand
and you can put it someplace else,
would you be where your body is or
would you be where your brain is?
Do
Neither. So some people would say,
neither. Some people would say,
I would be where my brain is. Some people
would say, well, no, my body is who I am.
And that's when I see myself, that's
who I am. And some people would say,
maybe you're not, uh, maybe
you're somewhere in between.
A one project that I've been doing for
the last six years is that from going to
India where I've been teaching
Tibet and Buddhist monks and nuns,
western neuroscience. And the first
question that they asked me is, uh,
Doctor Chub Lou, when, uh, when
you die, where does the mind go?
And I said, that's it. That's
a really interesting question.
Um, but as a scientist,
I don't have an answer to
that. Uh, as a scientist,
I need to devise an experiment that will
test that hypothesis. And I don't know,
an experiment that can be
done to test that hypothesis.
So what happens when you take a
brand and you put it someplace else?
Where is the mind to,
I don't know if I don't have an
answer for you at this time. Um,
but if you look at the brain,
we know that when you change the brand,
you also change various
aspects of the mind.
And one very important part is
this outside rind of the brand.
Does anybody know the name
of this outside partner?
We were channel your high school or your,
your university nursing. What's that? Uh,
not time for the cerebellum yet.
Cause it's folded outside. Part
frontal cortex would be the front
part of the brand. And so in general,
this general area without the frontal
would be the, that would be the cortex.
The cerebral cortex and cortex comes
from the Latin word, meaning bark,
not of a tree, but of the bark,
the outside rind of the cortex.
And you can actually see how that camp
of that cortex kind of does cover that
entire part of the brain. Uh, so inside
the brain we also have a strip here.
It's not labeled here,
but this is that a 200 million axons,
which connect the right and left
hemisphere. It's got two words to it.
Both start with the letter c,
anybody that's the corpus
callosum connecting the left
and the right hemisphere.
And this area here, it's
uh, it's sort of central.
It sends information up to the CORTEX
and also gets information from the spinal
cord as well. Kind of a
relay sensory information to
various parts of the CORTEX.
The cortex also receives part of it.
It doesn't make me the name of
that starts with the letter t, t.
H that's the founders. That's
right. That's the Thalamus here.
And so if that's the thalamus there,
below the thalamus would be what?
That would be the hypothalamus.
Thank you. And this part here,
the middle part of the brain and neck,
it's a big hint.
It's the middle part of the brain.
So it's what,
okay,
the middle.
What's that?
Hmm.
So obviously the midbrain, that's what
it's called. That's the midbrain there.
And then this cauliflower like thing
on the back. If I was juggling,
lean on one foot and hopping up and down,
this part of the brain
would be very active.
Also helps me with my balance and posture.
Now is the time for now's
the time for cerebellum.
So that's about 10% of your
brain and the cerebellum here.
And then from about this area
to the top of the spinal cord,
it would be like the
bottom part of the flower,
which would make it the brand
that would make it the brainstem.
And inside the brand step is
one area called the Medulla.
And uh, for them, some of
you that are old like me,
may have seen the movie
with a Adam Sandler.
How many have you seen waterboy come on,
you can admit it.
Now I have to watch all these movies
for scientific reasons, but there's one,
there's one scene in, in
waterboy with uh, the, uh,
professors talking about how,
uh,
alligators have a large Medulla Oblongata.
And if you remember this scene,
uh, he says it's, they have a large,
we do a lot of work on and that's
why alligators are always angry,
implying that the medulla has some
important function for emotional behavior,
which I don't know if,
I don't know evidence that that's true.
So I would suggest not to get your science
from especially maybe adding Sandra
or Hollywood. Uh, and now what about
the Brian? This is an average size,
a model of the brain, uh, about how much
is an average adult human brain where,
all right,
so I think three pounds and the
other guesses, two and a half,
two and a half kilos.
So that's about six pounds or so.
Yeah.
Any other guesses?
One of those answers is correct.
So, so, so on average average adult
human brain weighs about three pounds,
almost three pounds.
And I always bring this up and,
and I guess no one ever saw
it about two years ago on TV,
there was a TV show.
It was like a drama.
And I don't know if it was a drama or
a comedy, it was called three pounds.
It was on for like three episodes,
I think on CBS.
Anybody see that movie called three
pounds? Now? Nobody's watched.
That's why it's not on anymore.
It was all about a neurosurgeon
and then called it three pounds.
I assumed because the adult human
brain weighs about three pounds a.
What about gender or sex?
Are there any differences between
male and female brain weights?
You take a brand new prop and on a
scale and you weigh it. On average,
our average male brains heavier than
male than female brains or female brains
heavy than male brands,
or do they weigh about the same?
So raise your hand if you think on
average an average adult male brain weighs
more than an average adult or
female brain. So a few people.
How about on average female brains?
Way more than male brains.
And how about on average? The way about
the same. Okay, so let's look at some, um,
some real data.
So on this graph here,
on the x axis is how old someone
is on the y axis is brain weight.
Three pounds is about 1.4 kilograms.
So you can see there,
uh,
the red bars are male brain weights
and blue or female brain weights.
What does this graph show?
So females have smaller brands in men.
I want showed this graph to a group of
fourth graders and the fourth graders,
they were able to understand the x and
the y and they can see that some bars
were bigger than the other and they
can see that the red bars were larger.
And I called him this little boy and
I said, what does this graph show?
And the boy, you know, he's very
confident. He raises his hand and he says,
this graph shows that men
are smarter than women.
And I said something
scientific like, uh, you know,
that's a very interesting interpretation
of this data. I don't know exactly,
I don't know exactly what
I said, but I, you know,
I didn't want to make fun of him and
I didn't want to say who, you know,
you're wrong,
but I,
I did say that this graph doesn't say
anything about how smart someone is the
same graph. I showed her a group of
science teachers and one of the teachers,
she was giving me the, Oh, you know,
raising her hand and not letting me speak.
And I say, what's wrong? You know,
you have to take a cell phone call,
you have to go out, you know
what's wrong? And she said,
you should never show this picture. And
I said, why should I show this picture?
This has been published a long time ago.
It's been replicated many times. This is,
this is a fact. Why shouldn't
I show this picture? She said,
you're trying to show that men are
smarter than women. And I said,
this graph doesn't say anything about
how smart somewhere knows. And in fact,
this next graph has exact same data,
but it's plotted how large the brain
is in proportion to the whole body.
So this is brain body ratio.
So how large the brain is in
relation to the whole body.
So if I weigh 150 pounds in,
my brain weighs three pounds,
that means my brain is 2% of my total body
weight. Now when you look at the data,
there's almost no differences.
All right? Uh, and, uh,
even this graph doesn't say anything
about how smart some, because look,
a newborn baby and newborn baby's brain
is 13% of their total body weight.
And so, uh, you, uh,
who anybody here who has a little infants
at home or have seen babies know that
those babies have giant balloon
heads, right? Little bodies, right?
Their brains are 30% of how much
they were. And so just because, uh,
someone has a large brand,
has a larger brain from a portion of
their body says nothing about their
intelligence. Uh, we are not the animals
on earth with the largest brains. Uh,
elephants,
dolphins and whales have large
absolute brain sizes than we do.
We're not the animals on earth with
the largest brains in proportion to our
bodies. There's a several
animals. One is a hummingbird.
Hummingbirds have larger
brains for their body.
And there's another little African knife
fish. It's only about this big. And, uh,
again, tiny, tiny little brains,
but in proportion to their body,
they're larger than they are in us humans.
So it goes to the question,
what does it mean to be intelligent?
And we can talk a little bit about
that after as well. So the brain, uh,
is made up, is about three
pounds, 1.4 kilograms.
It's made up of special cells
called neurons or nerve cells.
And there's a whole lot of
those 86 to 100 billion.
We're just rounding up to a 100 billion,
but what's,
what's 14 billion between friends, right?
Uh, and they have those special parts.
They have dendrites receive
information from other cells, uh,
from other nerve cells.
They send that information to a cell body,
cell bodies connected to a long Axon,
which is a neuro fiber,
which then can branch
two terminals at the end.
And those terminals are very interested
because to nerve cells to communicate,
they don't actually touch,
there's a gap,
a physical gap between new to nerve cells.
So when the terminal of one cell a wants
to talk to a dendright of another nerve
cell, there's a space. And
so for one nerve cell to talk
to the other nerve cells,
the first nerve cell must release
the little chemical neurotransmitter.
You've probably heard some of these
dopamine, Acetylcholine, Gaba, glutamate,
Serotonin,
those are all types of chemicals that are
stored in the terminal of a nerve cell.
So each neuron is like a little battery
and then it generates a little bit of
electricity. When that electricity
gets to the end of the nerve cell,
it constants as chemists
calls to come out,
those chemicals cross
that small little space.
They're picked up by receptors on
the dendright of next nerve cell,
which can then increase or decrease the
likelihood I'm an electrical signal in
that next nerve cell. And that's
how signals are sent in your brain,
electrical signals within a nerve cell
and chemical signals between nerve cells.
So if you don't remember anything,
uh, else that we have to say today,
if you just remember that I,
I'd be very, very happy. Okay.
Electrical inside of a nerve cell
and chemical between nerve cells.
So let's talk a little bit about
what our brain does for us. Uh,
some of the basic things are taking in
sensory information from the outside
world,
processing that information and sending
a motor response act on that sensory
stimulus.
And this is just a couple of animals
that do things with their senses better
than we can do. For example, in
the upper left there is a cat.
What can a cat do with it?
Senses better than we can do.
So they have a good sense of
balance. Yeah. So, uh, don't do this,
but if you have a cat at
home and you drop it, uh,
it'll probably land on its feet because
it has a good sense of balance. Yeah.
They can also see in low light they
have a good sense of smell and very good
sense of hearing as well. Uh,
how about that? That Butterfly,
what can a butterfly do?
Is it senses better than we can do?
They can see infrared is
one. Yeah, that's right.
There's one more as actually nick, not
infrared. Ultraviolet is they see it,
they see ultraviolet.
They can do one other thing in a much
more sensitive than than we can do smell.
Yeah. They have a, they can detect very
low concentrations of certain chemicals,
pheromones in the air that we don't know
that's there. Uh, what about a shark?
Sharks have a particular sense that
humans don't have it all? Uh, yeah,
we can smell, but, uh, I heard
someone say that they have,
they can detect electricity in the water,
uh,
not because they use
refrigerators or electric razors,
but because they have the ability to
detect, uh, electricity generated by, uh,
muscles.
So that's one way that they can find
prey is by detecting electricity.
Uh,
put off by muscles.
A infrared is those snakes
a dolphin's navigate with,
um,
echolocation sonar or the emails
also have electrode receptors,
a chameleon I put up there because,
uh, some chameleons, you know, they,
they had their eyes on stocks and they
can put one eye up and one or down at the
same time. I've have no idea how they
put together that visual picture,
whether they see split screen or whether
it's unfocused or I don't know what
they see. Owls, owls,
we have a good sense of sight
and also a good sense of vision.
But our senses are also
very easy to trick.
And so what I want you to do on this one,
how many of you have heard of the stroop
effect before? Just a couple of years.
So good.
And so what I want you to do is I'm
going to point at these colors and I just
want you to say out
loud what color you see.
And these colors are just normal colors.
For example, the blue, it's just blue.
It's not a royal blue or dark
blue or navy, it's just blue.
Same with the green is not Jello Green.
It's not lime green, it's just green.
And really try, don't, don't mess
up the person sitting next to you.
Really try to say what color you see.
Some people see this as purple.
Some people see this pink, I don't
care. It's whatever you see. Okay.
So follow the bouncing ball and again,
say out loud what color you see. Okay.
Ready? One, two, three, go. Blue.
Good.
So just to, just to
test that one more. Uh,
so I wonder why aren't you doing this one?
What I want you doing.
This one is do not read the word.
Tell me what color the word is.
Printed it.
So this one on that word is printed
in black on that color that's printed.
That's green, right? Do not read the word.
Tell me what color the word is
printed there. Okay. Ready? One, two,
three.
Go.
Right.
I just checked it. Let's do it one more
time. First two are blue. Red, right.
Okay, here we go. Ready? One, two, three,
go.
Blue.
Not so easy. Now let's try one more
time. Let's try this one. Ready?
One, two, three, go.
Three.
So why can you do this one and you
couldn't do the other one because are you
getting the same information on this one
as you did from this one? Because look,
that's red. Red. This is
green. G. R. E. E. N. Y.
Can you do this one and you
couldn't do the other one?
Aren't you getting the same information?
Why can you do this one?
We can't do the other
one because of course,
right. It just shows that, that
we're not so good at multitasking.
And just the simple ability of being able
to read interferes with our ability to
name the color.
Can anybody read Japanese?
So if these were Japanese
Kanji characters for color,
would you be able to accept for
him? Uh, would you be able to, uh,
read the color that you see? Yes.
Because it has no meaning to you,
but because it has meaning to him, he
would probably have the same difficulty.
Right?
Uh,
what I want you to on this one is I want
you to stare on either this one or the
other one right there with a turquoise,
black and yellow means I want you to look
right there and keep on staring there
for about 10 seconds off.
Countback so keep on staring there.
Keep on staring. I'm going to
count backwards. If you blink,
go back to that same
spot. 10, nine, eight,
seven, six, five, four, three,
two, one. Keep on staring.
Blink once or twice
and you should see something there.
Now what's different than
what you were staring at?
So raise your hand if you saw the flag
of Canada. Yeah, I mean you saw the red,
white and blue flag. So, uh, is there
a red, white and blue flag up there?
Somebody said yes. No I, there's no
red, white and blue flag up there.
Cause made this slide and I never
made it and I never put a red,
white and blue flag up there. But you
still saw a red, white and blue flag.
But will you agree that it's not
there but you saw one. So where is it?
If it's not that,
I would say it's up in here.
And what is happening there is
when you stare at that Turquoise,
yellow and black flag, you're adapting
the visual system to those turquoise,
yellow and black colors. So when you
look at white, you're seeing white minus.
That input from I took was the other one
black and your brain interprets that as
red, white, and blue.
Uh, how about this one?
Now you know that they're kind of
illusions that are fooling your senses,
but does that square look like a perfect
square or does it look like the tops
and sides are kind of bashed down? Yeah,
you kind of see that it squeezed in,
but even though that you
know it's an illusion,
it's very hard to not see that illusion.
How many of you on this one see a
upside down white triangle? Yeah.
So if there's an upside down
on white triangle there,
now where is it now?
Yeah,
cause I never did anything
to a white triangle.
All I did just now was removed black
lines and now I just added black lines.
So I never edited a white triangle again.
You see a white triangle.
Is there a white triangle up there?
Some of you are going like,
and some of you are, I don't think
know what's going on now. Yeah.
No point triangle here.
No white square
and no white square.
Uh,
I see a white square and this one I know
there's a white skirt because I put it
there.
Um,
so I would claim that that your
brain is just trying to help the,
that's what the brain is doing.
It's just there to help.
Now how about this one is a, was going
to go completely across that a rectangle.
Would it be a perfect match with B would
be a perfect match with C or maybe I'm
trying to trick you and it's lined up
somewhere in the middle or on either side.
So raise your hand if you think that egg
would would be a perfect match with B.
Raise your hand.
So speed people over here.
How about it's a perfect match with C
and how about I'm trying to trick it and
match up with anywhere. See
Timmy, Timmy, Timmy, this is,
this is fascinating because here
we have about 30 or 40 people.
You're all looking at the same thing and
you're coming up with different answers
and it didn't seem to be that
everybody over here said,
hey everybody over here said B
and people over here said seats.
It was kind of distributed around. Why?
If you're looking at the exact same image,
are you coming up with different answers?
Because it's ambiguous. And so maybe I'm
also, maybe I'm also leading you, so,
so for example, uh, if to, to lead you
again, go ahead and put your hands,
hands like this.
And now what I want you to do is point
your thumbs at each other and now keep on
rotating around,
point them down,
and then take your right hand and put it
under your left hand and interlock your
fingers. And as your fingers are, point
them out like that. So you don't, yeah,
I don't hit anybody in front of
you. Yeah. Okay. So with your hands,
like this pointed out in front of you,
now all I want you to
do is rotate like this.
Of course I did. Of course
I did. Uh, but again,
it's just because, um, uh, because uh,
a little distraction altered the way that
you think and altered the way that you
perceive. And perhaps that's the same
with this one is because you have certain
expectations and your brain is just trying
to help you make sense of the world.
So it's uh,
it's actually a bit,
so maybe I was trying to
trick you by trying to trick
you by trying to trick you.
All right. Uh, and as I said,
the brain is just trying to help.
So even though your brain doesn't
get all the information it needs,
you can still read the sentences.
For example, the top line says what?
And the bottom line says, yeah, and the
brain is just, they're trying to help you.
So even though your brain doesn't
get all the information it needs,
it is just there to help.
So I want to turn this over to Dr. Johnson
and she's going to tell you about one
of her favorite things.
Brain computer interfaces.
One of my favorite things,
I don't know,
raindrops and roses are
red thing right there. Um,
so Eric asked me to put together some
slides that would be probably interesting
and kind of about the book and I thought
we should talk about brain computer
interfaces because it's very topical.
If anybody's been reading
the news this morning,
there's some stuff about brain computer
interfaces and also cause I thought this
might be sort of a tech friendly crowd
that you guys might be into. Some of that.
So when we talk about brain
computer interfaces are BCIS,
there's usually two categories
that we think about it.
So the first would be motor bay, Spring
food, your interfaces, and then sensory,
which would be kind of the opposite.
So when you're talking
about a motor based Vci,
the first thing we need to do is measure
the electrical potential. The brain.
And if you guys were listening
while Eric was talking,
he said that our brains use electricity
to communicate, which is true.
And it's also extremely convenient as
engineers because we know a little bit
about electricity, right? So we
know how to record electricity,
we know how to produce electricity
and that gives us some options for
interfacing with the nervous system.
So once we've measured
that electrical potential,
then we need to decode the
signal. So often when I give
this talk to kids, I say,
it doesn't come out in English and
it doesn't come out in Spanish.
And it's like a revelation to everyone in
the room. What does it come out as? Um,
and I had a woman come up to me one time
after I gave this talk at a bookstore
and she said, how do you do that?
Really? How do you do that? Um,
and it turns out that you need to do a
lot of signal processing in order to do
that.
So when we talk about decoding,
what we're really talking
about is looking at the time,
frequency analysis of the signal and
trying to figure out how that corresponds
to behaviors that we might observe.
Um,
then we use that decoded signals
to control an external device.
So it's a bit of a misnomer to say
it's a brain computer interface because
sometimes the computer doesn't
really get into the mix much at all.
Then when we had the sensory device,
we're usually going exactly
the opposite direction.
We want to measure a physical signal in
the world. So a physical signal might be
light, right? We could measure photons.
So we can measure sound
and measure pressure.
We can measure all kinds of
interesting things about the world.
We could measure IRR if we wanted to.
Um,
then we encode the signal into
an electrical pattern, um,
which is sort of trying to figure out
the opposite of this problem and then
electrically stimulate the brain.
So one of the fun things about the brand
is that if you pump a little bit of
current and you usually get some
sort of response on the other end,
if you do it in the right way, then you
can get meaningful sensory responses. Um,
and because,
uh,
brain computer interfaces are generally
thought of is therapeutic in some way,
then that's what we want on the other
end is a meaningful sensory response.
Um,
and while it might sound futuristic,
there's some of these already running
around out there in the real world. Um,
so let's go over some of the
ones that currently exist.
Does anybody know what this is right up
here? Cochlear implant? Yes. Very good.
Um, so a cochlear implant is a stimulating
device for people that have profound
hearing loss or deafness.
And what you're looking at here is
just the external portion of it, um,
which has the microphone and also
some of the signal processing parts.
And then on the inside there's actually
an array of electrodes implanted in the
Cochlea, which is that snail
shaped part of the inner ear. Um,
and they stimulate through the
electrodes into that space in the ear.
It stimulates the auditory nerve
and causes the perception of sound.
Uh, these have been around for
quite a while now, since the 80s,
and it turns out that there are so good
now that people can actually hear speech
and identify speech even in the
absence of visual cues. So for example,
on a telephone,
a person with a cochlear implant would
be able to understand speech and you
probably notice that this
person is small and bald,
meaning what? It's a baby. All right.
So why would you put a
cochlear implant in a baby?
So they will have the chance
to learn how to speak, right?
So we have kind of all of the
facets of this answer going around.
So the idea is that your
brain goes through critical
periods where you learn how
to interpret different kinds
of sensory information.
And critical periods usually
happen very early in life.
I think I can say they exclusively
happened early in life when your brain is
developing. And if you don't receive
sensory inputs during that period,
you will never really
learn how to interpret it.
So if you don't get auditory
information when you're very young,
you just don't learn how to hear. You
don't learn how to interpret speech. Um,
and so they found that the earlier you
can put it in the device in to a deaf
individual,
the more they're going to be able to
understand hearing an auditory signals
later in life. It's
extremely controversial. Why?
Okay,
sorry.
Because consent is an issue, right?
And infant isn't capable of consenting.
Um, this is, you know, it's actually
a very minimally invasive surgery.
Eye Surgeries go,
but it is a surgery and a lot of
people consider it an elective surgery.
A lot of members of the deaf community
consider deafness not really to be a
disability and not really to be
a problem that needs solving. Um,
and I don't really have any great
insights or solutions on this.
I just pointing out this is in
fact a problem that comes up, um,
and brain computer interface land.
Um,
this next one down here we have
a less young individual, um,
with this particular implant.
Does anybody know what this is?
Kind of. It's close. So
it is a visual implant.
A retinal implant. Yeah.
So this is the artist two,
which is developed by second sight.
It has recently,
I think 2013 received FDA approval.
So there are people at
various places in the country,
very centers in the country that are
actually implanting these retinal implants
for people that have, um, total vision
loss. So they're completely blind. Um,
and the rental implant is like you
might guess, implanted on the retina.
Retinal Anatomy has sort of
a strange naming convention.
So front and back might not mean exactly
what they seem like they should mean,
but in any case it's implanted.
Um, on the surface of your retina,
that sort of touches all that gooey
eyeball jelly stuff in the middle.
That's where the implant is.
Um,
there's a camera right in the middle
of these glasses and the camera is
recording.
The visual scene is doing
a lot of processing on that
information to get it to,
uh, sort of, uh, I can't remember how
many contacts they have, but it's,
it's on the order of like
a hundred electrodes are on
the surface of the retina
and then it stimulates the retina,
the,
the remaining cells on the retina
with that digital information.
Um, there's a couple of conditions
where this is really good. Uh,
so if you have a what's called
age related macular degeneration,
then your photo receptors cells
degenerate over time on the retina.
That's one condition where
this is an appropriate device.
The other one would be retina and tie,
retinitis Pigmentosa,
which is actually a heritable condition
where people also progressively lose
their photoreceptors. But in
both of those conditions, um,
the rest of the cells in the
retina tend to be preserved.
So it's useful to have a retinal implant.
It's not useful to have a retinal implant.
It's her blind because you don't
have eyes, right? If you lose an eye,
retinal implant isn't going to
do really all that much good.
There are kinds of other visual implants
that people are developing and you can
have a cortical implant.
There are some groups that are
working on a syllabic implants.
This is kind of a different idea.
Um, does anybody know what this is?
Somebody said something, but I didn't
hear what it was. All right, cool.
Underscore substitution or vision.
Exactly. That's totally what it is.
This is what we call a tactile visual
sensory substitution device, right?
So the idea is you take visual
information, he's wearing
the really cool glasses,
again,
with the camera on the front,
taking that visual information and
turning it into a tactal input.
So tactal input is what I'm holding
in my hand so everybody can sort of
touch your sense of touch.
Um, and in this case,
they're not putting it on
the guy's fingertips because
you use your fingers for
a lot of stuff,
especially if you're blind.
They're putting it in this cool headband.
Right on his forehead.
I've also seen them on the tongue.
Um,
you can also put them on
the back or the neck. Um,
you have a different distribution of
sensory receptors across the surface of
your body.
So there are some places where you're
going to get better acuity from this than
others.
Um,
but this is also a kind of
brain computer interface,
a much less invasive kind of
brain computer interface. Um,
so moving on to motor kinds of brain
computer interfaces. This guy up here, um,
has a very severe spinal cord injury.
Um,
you can see he's actually on a respirator,
so he has a complete transection of
his spinal cord, um, very high. Um,
and uh, so when I give this talk
to students, I usually say, well,
he was in a knife fight and the first
thing we should learn from this is that
nobody should get in a
knife fight. Right? Um,
and that's still good advice
even if you're not a kid. Um,
so this thing that looks like a plug
that's going into his brain is in fact a
plug that's going right into his brain.
Okay.
So the scientists at Brown University
as part of this research venture called
braingate have implanted electrodes
into the part of his brain that used to
control movement of his arm and his hand.
Um,
and then when they record
the activity of those cells,
when he's thinking about or trying
to move his arm or his hand,
they turn that into a signal which
controls a computer cursor on a screen.
And this was really one of the first
demonstrations of a human brain computer
interface.
And this group has continued to develop
the technology and then now have people
moving really fancy robotic
arms exclusively with brand
power and it's all very
scifi and very cool. Um, so this is,
uh, another kind of motor based
brain computer interface. So, uh,
this person obviously has
had an amputation as a result
of a motorcycle accident.
So the lesson there is everyone would
be very careful when you're riding a
motorcycle. All right. Um,
and she's very lucky because she went to
the Rehabilitation Institute of Chicago
and they tried out this new technique
where they took the severed nerve stump
that was leftover after the amputation
and they pulled out the motor part of the
nerve. Right? So you have, um, the,
the nerves that are going down or,
yeah,
the neurons that are the axons of the
neurons that are going down to innovate
the muscles.
And then you also have the sensory
receptors that are coming back to give
information to your brain.
So they took out the motor part of that
and they actually implanted it in the
pectoral muscle right here.
Um,
and then after those nerve roots sort
of grew back and innovator the pectoral
muscle, when she thought about
moving her arm or her hand,
it actually cause contraction
of that muscle. Um,
and then they can put electrodes on the
surface of that muscle delay detecting
the electrical activity of the muscle
and then use that to control this really
tremendously complicated robotic arm.
So now when she thinks about moving her
hand, the robotic hand actually moves,
which is super cool.
And then also got sort of a bonus with
this and that the sensory nerves also
grew back and innovative that
pectoral muscle. So now, um,
when you press on different parts of that
muscle and the skin overlay now muscle,
it actually feels like somebody is
pressing on her fingertips, right?
So then they can instrument the arm
that can put pressure detectors on the
fingertips and she can
actually get sensory feedback.
So we actually have a closed loop brain
computer interface and that's nice.
Um, down here is another kind of
motor based brain computer interface.
So this is a for people that have high
but not very high level spinal cord
injury. So it's for people that have
a c six or c seven level injury.
It comes out of the Cleveland
Clinic in Cleveland. Um,
and it's actually called the free hand.
And the idea behind this is that they
implant electrodes right into the muscle
bodies.
They have seven electrodes
that get implanted into the
muscle bodies in the arm.
People that have that level of injury,
that c six c seven,
they have movement and their shoulder
and they can usually extend their elbow,
but they can't grasp or on
grasp their hand. Right?
So what they can do is stimulate those
muscles. When you stimulate the muscles,
they can trapped. Um, and if you
do it in the right order, you want,
you get on the other end are functional,
isn't it?
So it's called functional
electrical stimulation. Um,
so what they're able to do,
even with seven electrodes,
it's not nearly as many electrodes,
is you have muscles in your arm and you
have about 30 muscles controlling your
arm.
So seven is just a small subset of that.
They're able to give people a
few different kinds of grass.
And even with those few
different kinds of grass,
people are able now to really
enhance their independence,
right? So they can brush their
teeth where before they couldn't,
they can feed themselves,
they can do all kinds of ivy if even seen
pictures of people playing tennis with
the [inaudible] system where they
couldn't have done that before. Um,
so unfortunately this device
is no longer available.
And one of the reasons for that is because
it's only useful for people that have
this very specific level of injury.
And why would that be the case?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
um,
that's a good point to think about
sort of spasticity issues. Um,
and that's specificity is always an issue
when you have a spinal cord injury. Um,
and it's also very unpredictable,
but that's actually not the case.
That's not the,
it's not the driving factor here.
Right? So the economics are the
reason why it's not broadly,
you know,
commercializable.
But the reason it's only really useful
to people that have this c six c seven
level injury is because these people
can move their shoulder and shoulder
movement is important because there
was no brain part of this device.
You have to be able to communicate
with this device in some way. Right.
And so the way that they did it,
as they put a joystick on the wheelchair
with the contralateral soldier shoulder
and they're able to move the joystick
by moving their shoulder around.
So recently,
there have been some people that have
tried to sort of connect this with this to
connect to the whole brain control
interface part with the muscle control.
There's a group at all Ohio state that
did it. A proof of concept does this, um,
last year.
Um,
so that's sort of the state of the
art and brain computer interfaces.
And I think Eric wants to take
you a different direction.
Yeah. Just, just the opposite direction.
At least brought you all
the way to the future.
I'm bringing you all the way back to
the past way in the past where for many
years people have looked up to the moon
and have assign blame to the moon for
many different reasons. So we
get the word lunacy, right?
The root word lunacy comes from
the word Luna meaning moon. Right?
And for many years people have tried to
assign blame to the moon for things like
traffic accidents, uh, domestic
violence calls, uh, poisoning, suicides,
murders,
violence.
And these data are relatively
easy to extract, right?
You go to the police blotter,
you go to the Almanac and you can see
what phase of the moon and match it up to
a particular day and count how many
accidents or traffic accidents or,
or what.
And there've been a close to a hundred
different studies looking at a lot of
these different behaviors.
And there's no evidence to suggest that
the phase of the moon affects behavior
in any way. Now that won't dissuade many
people. And in fact, uh, at my house,
we had someone over at the house, I
won't mention her name, uh, but she, uh,
is in law enforcement and you know,
at my house somehow,
I don't know how we end up
talking about the brain.
Don't ask me how that
happens. But, uh, and we, the,
the full moon came up and she said,
Oh, uh, you know, uh, you know,
when I'm out on patrol,
uh,
I pulled more people out of the ditch
and I go to more domestic violence cases
when that full moon is
out. And I said, well,
don't do things happen at other times
of the month. And she said, well, yeah,
it happens, but I just don't
notice it. And I said, exactly.
Because if you look at the literature,
you'll find that almost no correlation
between the phase of the moon and any of
these unusual abnormal
behaviors, uh, and really, uh,
the physics of it don't make sense to you
do that. The gravitational pull of the,
uh, on the earth just don't match
the, uh, in, in the human body.
So there's really no reason for it.
But the people that have the strongest
beliefs that the moon does affect
behavior are people in law
enforcement and medical personnel.
And my hypothesis is that these
professions that are high stress jobs,
that they see bad things happen,
they seem horrific accidents.
And if they can assign blame
to something like the moon,
then it relieves stress from
him. Now I, that's my hypothesis.
Whether it's true or not,
I don't know. But again,
if you look at the types of professions,
and there have been studies about who
holds the strongest beliefs at are those
and very high stress positions.
Yeah.
Yeah. So that's, that's one
hypothesis is why, why did,
why did it originally come up?
And some people said, well,
maybe in the old days before
there is artificial light, uh,
the artificial light provided a
thieves and robbers and, uh, more, uh,
light to do their nefarious actions. And
then the police could also see them. Uh,
and so that would cause,
so that's one hypothesis about why,
but why that might be
why the myth started,
but why it is skill exists
when we have artificial life,
it doesn't really make sense. Um,
so why that, why that's the case?
Uh, we don't really know
for sure. Um, but, uh,
that's the end of our formal presentation.
I just want to again, thank David and,
and Google for having
us, uh, our publisher,
Norton and company and also the center
for sensory motor neural engineer who
both Lisa and I work. So, uh,
we have time for some questions.
Uh, you know, now it's kind of
your time, uh, that you know,
there's something about the brand and
you didn't know if it was true or not.
We might have an answer for you, uh,
or something that, yeah, we won't,
we won't make one out. Um, but, um,
if there's a question that
you have now as a time to ask,
so there's a lot of information online
about the pineal gland and specifically
how fluoride supposedly affects it
in some magical, mysterious way.
Are there,
is there any merit to these claims?
What is the peanut Atlanta
and how does it work?
Yeah, so the pineal Glen is a, is a,
is a gland pineal comes from
the word pine nut or pine.
This is a little pine cone shaped thing
right in the center of the brain. Uh,
the long history of it,
uh, is, uh, Dukart, uh,
originally thought that that was the seat
of the soul maybe cause it was in the
center of the brain. It releases a lot
of Serotonin. It might have some, uh,
uh, uh, function in circadian
rhythms and things like that,
but I haven't heard anything
about fluoride or its effect.
I haven't seen any on that. Um, so the
function of it, it's, it's a, it's a,
not like a gland.
Um,
might have to do with some circadian
rhythms and things like that,
but I haven't heard anything specifically
about flora as a neuroscientist.
I mean the, the field of
neuroscience is so huge that, uh,
you know, I, I kind of know my area,
but what's happening in other areas,
it's very difficult with thousands and
thousands of papers being generated every
year. And in fact, you know,
for the book, I have haven't,
I know I wrote some of the quiet,
the answers to the questions,
but at least brings a whole area
of expertise that I don't have a,
and that's kind of like, you
know, a question like that is,
it's very hard to follow the
most recent literature. Um,
but I haven't heard anything about it yet.
So it's a,
we are now able to decode a electrical
information from the brain for things
that like related to, uh, um, like our,
our modem functions and, and sensory, uh,
are we close to actually be able to do
the same of decoding brain electrical
information, uh, with the goats to higher
level, uh, brain functions like, you know,
memory and perhaps coaches thinking again
and so forth every even close to that
have you up to music about it.
Um, so I think it's, it's kind of
an interesting question because,
so there's a lot of different kinds
of higher level thinking, right?
So memory is a little bit different then
like higher order cognitive function
because there's a very specific part of
the brain that we know is very involved
in memory formation and people have been
recording activity from the hippocampus.
If I'm that Perry Hipaa Campbell areas
for a really long period of time and can
record a lot of how those memory
traces are laid down and stored.
Um,
and in some cases they say that they
can tell exactly what memories are being
recalled at any given time.
So I think in that case we're a lot closer
than what we would be in some of the
other higher order thinking.
When you're talking about
higher cognitive processes,
you're usually talking about
frontal areas. Um, and when
I was in graduate school,
we called it the prefrontal
Cortex, right? Like there's,
there's so much stuff going on in there,
there's so much association that I think
it's really hard to piece apart any
individual thing.
Um,
and so when you get down to this room
more basic functions like motor or
sensory,
I think there's a much higher probability
that we'll be able to decode those
functions specifically.
Um, which is, but you know,
but there are certain things you can
tell like, so for example, there's a,
what we call the error related negativity,
which you can record from EEG when
somebody has made a mistake and they know
that they've made a mistake in
a task, you can record that. Um,
when somebody sees something that's
surprising and also meaningful to them,
there's an EEG signature to that
that people can record as well.
So there are certain things
that you can pick out,
but in terms of just decoding somebody's
thoughts or a stream of consciousness I
think were really long way from that.
I have a question about one of the
of this brain computer interfaces.
There was a guy who this other stuff
can to get spray and he was like
[inaudible] a malls.
Like of course our halls.
So how does it or doesn't like a
passion like four I looked throats good
songwriting, rob them area of the brain
or find like particular specific area.
And so
dusk you have to train that Shelia
speak of all cell phones things or
right. So I'm in this case, they're
usually implanting thinking Utah, right,
which was developed in Utah. Um, and it
has about a hundred electrodes on it.
Um,
and they're all sort of shaft
style electrodes and you
plant them all within one
very small area of the brain.
And in this case they really want to
target the part of the brain that used to
control and movement of
the hand or the harm.
Because the idea is that that will be the
most natural way to control the device.
So usually they would put the person in
an Fmri scanner and then they would have
the person to think about
moving their hand or arm.
And that gives them a way to localize
the part of the brain that would be
involved with that.
And then in when they go into surgery,
they try and implant that right there.
Um,
but there is a fair bit of
training involved. Um, and it,
it actually gets very complicated.
You may have to train the device every
day because the neurons surrounding the
implant might also die or become
inaccessible for other reasons. Um,
so it's not as if you put the implant
in and then you can magically just move
your arm the way that you used to.
Or you can move a computer
cursor without effort.
You do have to train on the device.
So normally we have the ability to ask,
moving our arm without
actually moving at this.
Is this person using
the sooner or interface?
He just mashes moving.
Disarm is the just that aren't
really wants it to whatnot. Um,
that's a good question. Um, so
when we imagine moving our arms,
it's actually the same part of our brain
is active is when we actually move our
arms at least.
So I should say the part of the brain
that they're recording that same part of
the brain is active whether you imagine
or whether you actually move your arm.
So presumably then if somebody had a
brain computer interface that they were
using every day in their life than if
they just sort of imagined using it,
that would also trigger
activation of the arm. Um,
maybe designers would think about that
and implement some sort of on off too.
I mean that's the thing that people
think about it for other reasons.
It's how can you inactivate your device
when you don't want it to be working. Um,
there's also, you know, there's just
a lot of plasticity in your brain.
The brain has a chance
to change itself a lot.
And I sort of would think,
I would hypothesize that your brain
might natively be able to overcome that
particular barrier.
Is it if you used it a lot?
Oh, dreaming is kind of a hard one. But,
so if you were in the phase of sleep
in rem sleep where you have these vivid
dreams.
I kinda think so if your devices on,
okay.
I've been,
but that's an interesting question and
it brings up additional questions that
say that either you're dreaming
and all of a sudden your arm moves,
or if you're walking down the street
and all of a sudden you're our moves and
say it interests someone,
maybe someone that's in the bed with you
or you're walking down the street and
then they had somebody that you don't
know who's responsible for that injury
that you caused with that arm
because you were sleeping.
It wasn't me that caused it.
It with the arm just moved by itself.
So who's responsible?
Is it the person who's our moved?
Is it the engineer who built the arm?
Is it the physician who installed the arm?
Or is it the programmer who
programmed that arm or the,
or decoded that signal and then sent that
signal out. Who's responsible for it?
So these are questions that in this
entire field that perhaps engineers and
neuroscientists are perhaps
not equipped to answer.
And at the center for sensory
motor neural engine where we work,
we are actually collaborating with
philosophers and newer ethicists and the
Department of Philosophy at the University
of Washington to ask some of these
questions because scientists
and engineers, sometimes
we can do these things,
but how should we do these things?
And,
and should we do these things are
questions that we don't always ask before
they're developed.
And so we're trying to get some of
these questions at least brought up and
discussed not only within our own
community but with the end users.
Those people that will be the
recipients of these devices,
they should have some say in what they're
going to do and what they can do and
what they can't do and what they look
like. Um, so these are, these are, uh,
you know, the, the, the
simple, not, not such a simple,
but the obvious questions lead to
many, many other questions, which are,
or deeper on so many different levels.
So you mentioned giving this talk to
Buddhists and I believe there was an
interesting outcome of the
Dalai Lama undergoing an MRI.
Are there any avenues of research
along those lines around self,
brain modulation,
etc?
Yeah, I, I don't know of the Dye
Lama himself, uh, undergoing an MRI,
but there have been,
uh,
there is research going on with Tibetan
Buddhist monks who have come to the
states,
uh,
and have been meditated in the scanners
and they're trying to correlate some of
the changes that go on in the
brain during meditation. Um,
to be honest, I don't know
if there's been a lot of, uh,
data that can be extracted to suggest
how we can become compassionate like they
are from, from the, from the literature.
Uh, but that's ongoing research.
And so what is the neural
basis of meditation, uh,
that might give rise to the neural
correlate of consciousness itself?
Uh, and you know, as scientists,
we've always tried to externalize
everything. You know, we,
we measure it in other people,
but consciousness and compassion,
something that comes from within.
And so maybe it's something that,
that we need to look within ourselves and
steady ourselves as opposed to studies
others to maybe get to some of
those questions. So, um, that,
that research is ongoing.
It's a relatively, very new,
a line of research combining a
meditation and modern neuroscience.
And I think the data's
still waiting to come on.
Thank you very much for coming and
answering a lot of questions at all.
[inaudible].